the iPhone 11 is officially here and the
main selling point of this is the fact
that it has three cameras so the quality
of the photos and video was increased
over the previous version but I'm going
to test it out with the note 10 plus I'm
back from taking photos and I really
wanted to get these photos and put them
on my computer so I can actually see
what they look like because it's really
difficult looking at photos on two
completely different screens so really
going in and doing a comparison like
this has been something that I wanted to
do for a while a huge thank you to Tyler
he's been helping me so much with all of
these videos he's helped me shoot these
he's helped me edit a bunch of them he
actually edited this one right now so hi
Tyler
so this first photo is my feet and also
Tyler's feet looking in the iPhone 11
and looking at the note 10 I feel like
the colors were way more true on the
iPhone 11 there's way more blue tint in
the note 10 photos like the black on my
pants it's more blue hue Tyler's shoes
are kind of blueish even the concrete is
a little blue and this is a really
zoomed in look at our feet again there's
not as much detail in the note 10 as
there is in the 11pro
this is another photo here this is just
a wide-angle shot of this treat and if
you look at the leaves on both of these
I feel like the you know 10 seems to
have pulled out a little bit more of
these shadows but overall I think both
of the photos look pretty good here's a
cute little slow side so the iPhone 11 /
looks a little more vibrant note 10
looks a little bit washed out both of
the skies look pretty even here's some
flowers and this was done with a
portrait mode and live focus and they
both did a pretty good job you can see
the iPhone it kind of struggled a little
bit behind here on these leaves
whereas I guess the the samsung also
struggled a little but let's just really
take a look at these flowers I think the
colors are way more accurate on the
iPhone most of you as you can see that
there's a couple different colors of
pink where is the note 10 seems to have
made those colors all a very similar
color both photos stand alone
they both look great like these are
these are two really good photos it's
interesting because in previous years I
feel like the iPhone did a really great
job of taking photos but sometimes it
would overcompensate it would make
things a little too bright I would love
the way that they looked but one of the
complaints that people had is it wasn't
true to what you were actually seeing so
I feel like this year they have made a
few changes and it definitely looks way
more realistic to what you're actually
seeing so here the front facing on the
Samsung Note x+ is it's really not very
good it's not terrible but it's not good
because it completely just like blurs
your skin and I made sure that I didn't
have any beauty filters or anything on
there's way more detail in the iPhone 11
Pro especially around the rocks and in
these leaves and even on my face like
the skin tone I feel like there's a
clear difference between the two of
these they see photos both look great it
does seem like the iPhone pulled in a
little more detail I'm a little more
sharpness here on the bricks and
although on the note 10 it looks like it
pulls in a little more detail and up the
shadows in the tree this is an
interesting shot so this was kind of
shooting directly into the Sun the note
10 did a pretty good job of pulling out
the shadows here in the trees and in
this house I kind of liked the note 10
picture a little bit more to be honest I
liked in the shadows and photos or
turned up a little bit unnaturally
that's sort of what happened here so any
times in Lightroom and I'm a photo I
take the shadows and I move them all the
way to the right so that they are pretty
completely at the max that they can be
hey I'm still I'm still a note 10 fan
because they feel like it did a really
good job of this photo particularly okay
this is where things seem to turn for
the note 10 because the wide angle on
here really distorted these flowers at
the bottom it also made me super bright
we're just fine cool I like it but with
that you tend to lose some details in
the face same photo zoomed in
again look at the face it just seems
very unnatural so like I feel like hmm
my body looks and looks something it
looks a little different like a little
like he took me and you went true
this is a live focus and a portrait mode
the note 10 has just completely
flattened this image the colors in my
shirt or a little washed out my pants
have a look tint to them so here's some
flowers and just take a look at these
white flowers right here like there's a
weird blue kind of I guess a light
effect or something happening here and
you don't see that at all in the iPhone
11 this is not a good example of how
great the iPhone does just keeping
everything very consistent if you look
at my face in comparison to the note 10
the note 10 looks a little contrasting
and these two photos I magically have
morphed from holding a cake to a coffee
cup so here's a portrait mode versalife
focus via live focus seems to be
focusing on the coffee cup a little more
here in the note 10 where's the 11pro
has got a little bit of the cake and a
little bit of that cupcake that looks so
good here's a little side-by-side
comparison of some video we had both of
these cameras mounted Nick to each other
so this is a little walk in talk
the note 10 actually looks pretty good
in comparison to the 11pro
I think it did a really good job of
pulling out the colors but again the
iPhone 11 seems to have kept everything
very consistent so nothing is
overexposed and this is some harsh
lighting conditions - so this is this is
kind of a difficult test
so look at this right here the entire
sky is completely blown out and then
note 10 it is struggling a lot with
these harsh lighting conditions and the
iPhone is staying true to those colors
and Wow
all right that just can we just pause
for a moment just take a look looking at
those two videos side by side the iPhone
11 pro is a clear winner in my eyes
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this video I loved
doing this test and doing photo
comparisons is one of the most fun
videos for me to do mostly because
you're just out there taking phone
photos and then you get to go back and
look at them and kind of analyze them
and see which ones you like the best a
lot of photography and art is personal
opinions so you guys might be looking at
these photos and you might like
something that I don't like anyway I
think the iPhone did a really great job
I mean the fact that we're getting a lot
of these shots out of just a cell phone
is incredible we also did a test of the
iPhone 11 diverse the pixel at night and
it's honestly amazing what these cameras
can do and that only makes me more
excited for the future speaking of the
future I'll be having some more videos
about the iPhone and some other fun
stuff coming up very shortly so make
sure you're subscribed and hit the bell
liked this video if you enjoyed it and
of course leave me some comments because
I really want to hear from you guys what
do you think of these photos I'll see
you guys in my next video
[Music]